this show is sponsored by betterhelp as
the world's largest therapy service
betterhelp has matched 3 million people
with professionally licensed and vetted
therapists available 100 online plus
it's affordable just fill out a brief
questionnaire to match with a therapist
and if things aren't clicking you can
easily switch to a new therapist anytime
it couldn't be simpler no waiting rooms
no traffic no endless searching for the
right therapist learn more and save 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
trash Tuesday that's betterhelp help.com
trash Tuesday hi guys next week I can't
believe it I'm finally coming to Phoenix
I cannot wait get your tickets now at
esteronice.com and don't forget to check
out my new solo podcast Audio Only it's
called my pleasure and it's available
where you listen to all your audio only
podcasts hello sluggies hello insanies
hello Stanis hello uh what else do I
call you uh or fans you guys are the
best I had so much fun on all these
episodes am I on this one
it's so fun to be here with you guys I
am also going to be on the road it is
here my favorite most exciting date
coming up is Las Vegas New Year's
December 30th and 31st come hang out
with me we're gonna party it's gonna be
absolutely the best I am so stoked for
that then I'm going to be doing a one
night or January 7th at Burbank in flap
at Flappers in Burbank I'm going to be
in Wisconsin in January I'm going to be
in Florida February and March and in
Canada a lot more shows are getting
added in different places so go to Annie
lerman.com shows to check them out also
after this show go over to anniewood go
to youtube.com Annie Letterman as my
solo podcast it's so fun we love it over
there think of it as a double feature
see you guys later
I can't um tap on my phone with gloves
on did you know that
ha ha
sorry the bullying me just came out yeah
I'm tip tapping away over here wait
who's that character on The Simpsons ha
ha oh yeah who is that I was gonna say
Cartman
oh no they're all blending this is for
you to like mess up those universes is
like really it's like weird why you
think I'm like a cartoon girl no like
it's just that could never happen to me
and so seeing like that you are capable
of why because your face is so round you
always know the round face characters he
has like Simpsons family guy and South
Park like they're just so different like
you cannot mesh them they are very
different
happy New Year hey yeah hey happy New
Years we're in the Roaring 20s ah we're
roaring
I we're in our 20s this is the only way
we can be in our 20s is to do this
episode that's so sad but do you
genuinely miss your 20s no
no not even a little bit and you know
what's funny is when I was that age and
you hear people older than you saying
like oh it gets better you're like yeah
right and then you get that age and
you're like oh my god when you're young
you suck you're so stupid you're
embarrassing yourself everywhere you go
like I feel like my 30s are just an
another
like try at my 20s where I'm smarter and
cooler remember the thinking people were
old too like people in their 30s were
almost like
my mom
had 12 year old kids yep you know what I
mean yeah you view her differently but
no you could I remember being 27 though
and fully believing I was peaking I was
like I think this is as good as it's
ever gonna get boy was I wrong 27 was a
good year though but it was like a it
was like can you imagine that being it
it's a fun age but it's still too young
like I don't I know they say your brain
isn't developed till 25 I think like
honestly 35 because you're under 35.
yeah hoping there's more room in there
but I remember overhearing a
conversation with my dad and his friends
once and they were talking about how
um Life Starts at 30 and I remember
thinking like that's insane I'm like 12.
what are they talking about and now I'm
like oh yeah it actually does yeah I I
can't wait to be like a hot 50-something
Laura Dern like that's sort of what I'm
striving for I don't know how my body is
gonna you know look at that age but I
think I'm I'm gonna be killing it at
that age you're gonna have to go a
little white face I think to whiten it
up a little bit do a little bleaching of
the skin I can see this for you oh my
God she goes blonde she [ __ ] Ben Harper
oh she was she married him or or she
bush had one of those not marriages but
was together so long and had bunch of
kids Laura Dern is really interesting to
me because of her Partners yeah he's not
the only
um um I guess like
straight not strange guy but you know
how like she can you pull up people at
all yeah he's like all tea
like he probably wore like silly jackets
a lot Baron Davis remember that I don't
remember that I remember that what this
is the man that Laura Dern has dated
so we have Baron Davis
who else Ben Harper common oh my God I
was like that Ben Harper looks like
common
[Laughter]
Billy Bob Oh Billy Bob's the weirdest
one whoa wait I told you guys my story
of when I met him right I think you did
wait what happened it was he was so
exactly like what you would expect him
to be
he um
he would my friend we we were like
hanging out during the this movie The
Astronaut Farmer that they were filming
in
in Santa Fe and my friend was hooking up
with I can't even say who it is but
someone that was on the movie it's like
for her own
it's so embarrassing I was like I
remember being like I had never seen
like someone be a star [ __ ] where I
was like that's who you're writing holy
[ __ ] and um and he this guy kept trying
to set me up with Billy Bob I was like
I'm good wait what I was 21 he was like
he's like I can get you Billy Bob if you
want like who knows if he could like it
wasn't like Billy Bob was like coming
for me but I was like I'm good like we
were just like these you know waitresses
and college students in Santa Fe I wait
can we pause here for a second like
isn't Billy Bob like a hot man icon I
never wanted to [ __ ] a celebrity I never
was like interested in that okay so I
was like a crew [ __ ] I like I liked
the guys with the calluses on their
hands just turn around sandbags check in
with you are you attracted to Billy Bob
Thornton I personally know
Carlos anyone can I tell you my favorite
Billy Bob moment is when he got
interviewed for his band and they kept
bringing up his acting career and he was
so mad will you look that up
it was so good okay wait okay so care
okay so anyway so my friend was hooking
up with this guy on the movie who was
very old and very not
Billy Bob and you rejected Angelina
Jolie's ex I didn't reject he I'm like I
want to be clear this was this other guy
being like you want Billy Bob I'll get
you build it I'm like what
um but so we go on set and we're in the
um craft services and Billy Bob Thorn
comes up and he goes
um like he she puts his hand on he goes
I'm Billy Bob Thornton International
Superstar
and I I think I said something like oh I
heard you were looking for me he was
like what and I was like I don't know I
just I don't I'm not famous anymore and
then um heard you were looking for me I
said something stupid I just like said
something I was like I don't know and um
I just wasn't allowing I wouldn't allow
the dominance and
um
his thumb was hurt for some reason I
don't remember why but anyway so he goes
um
he said do you know any virgins
immediately and I went I actually do no
virgin he goes can can you give me your
number and I go no
and then it was can I ask you a personal
question I said sure and he said
um is three inches too small and I said
it depends on the direction you're
holding the ruler
I was really proud of how quick I was
and that was my whole Billy Bob and then
like my friend's like I think I was like
I think you can get him too I don't know
wait it was just like but I think he was
he was playing up being like a creep
like that's disturbing it just seemed to
be a very like it seemed to be like a I
think we have a lawsuit on our hands
that is disturbing he was just being a
thing I don't know exactly who you
thought he would be it was just very
surprising how Billy Bob he was yeah
he's like ever so every girl he meets
he's just like do you know any virgins I
think he was just [ __ ] around okay
I do I do believe he was [ __ ] around
yeah oh I think he was [ __ ] around he
was doing like International Superstar
everything he was doing was like kind of
like this bit for like the craft service
people
okay but don't you feel like we know
actual men who like are looking for
virgins and I do know that and that's
why I can differentiate that he was like
doing a bit I'll tell you I 100 do we
know men who want virgin yes uh I mean
yes okay and one oh maybe two but
I just how is that fun
yeah it's like a psychological like
insecurity on their part I love like on
The Bachelor and stuff when you're
watching and a girl will be like
she'll be on like the you know almost to
the final episode and she's like I gotta
tell him I gotta tell him and she's like
I'm a virgin you see them they're like
yikes
[Applause]
some of them are like great and it's
like oh
why do you want that yeah let her live
her life pop that cherry somewhere else
Carlos if you wanna bring me the
pre-bloodied if you want to date with a
girl and it was like going there maybe
you're back at someone's place and then
she said she was a virgin would you be
more turned on or turned off can I
answer for him if he turned on because
it's a tighter puts in it mimics the
[ __ ] of a man
it wouldn't be weird it's too much
pressure right it's not even pressure on
me I would just be like confused as to
why they're a virgin like what's
happening now with a 19 year old it's
just strange or you're like super
religious or you know oh my God I just
got I just remembered something
one time in college I was hooking up
with this guy we're making out
and then he told me he was a virgin and
I was like
so you were the guy I was the good guy
that's like ew I was the opposite I
would say I I love a lot of um when I
was 16 I slept most of the boys that I
slept with between 16 and 18 were
versions I feel like everyone was a
virgin at that age I never had virgins I
was always I was always
the lesser of the wait Esther the
chances of a 16 17 year old boy being a
virgin is pretty high so if that's the
pool I'm picking from it's probably 50
50 right that's true but what was that
like for you were they like too excited
um I had just started [ __ ] too so I
guess it didn't feel weird it's like
yeah the chances of [ __ ] a virgin
when you're that age are pretty big it's
like the guys our age and older that are
we're like guys come on you had to
really go you had to go find these
people I mean it was a virgin you gotta
look it's nice it was I remember
thinking like oh my God they're gonna
remember my name forever that is okay
that's cool and also like at the safety
is it's cool and sick I'm kind of sick
but I remember thinking like oh I'm
there first like I feel honored I wonder
how many kalila tattoos there are not
just in this room oh my God I'm the
leader of this version no you're like a
hack like you like like so many have
come before you yeah like they're like
another kalila we've gotten like four
today
well I guess this is kind of New Year's
Eve themed like a rebirthing a virgin
yes yes yes it's a virgin year if there
was a way for you to put your hymen back
together
um
Humpty dumpty's a Yoni egg I will say
this I was really disappointed when I
had sex the first time and there was no
blood I was like what like I thought it
was a virgin like I swear the type of
pain was a different pain than I thought
it was going to be too yeah it didn't
hurt at all oh no mine hurts so bad you
big [ __ ] no like I got him that little
body it didn't hurt Jesus Christ like it
was a good hurt like no mine was like
was like a like a like I felt like I was
being bruised and cut at the same time
same wait what's your thought that since
I had been diddled and I got into a
pretty um brutal biking accident that
involved my [ __ ] being impaled she got
her she got Schwing
um I for sure thought that my hymen had
just been like like dissolved yeah but
it turns out
um it was excruciating for me I remember
after the first time I ever had sex I
was like I never want to do that again
that was horrible I was traumatized yeah
I was not sick my [ __ ] ached I had no
romance either did you have any romance
involved in yours there was but I didn't
have sex again for a year and a half
after my first time that's how much I
hated yeah me too what wait but weren't
you like hadn't some like had you been
like
I yeah that's what I thought I was like
oh for sure like I Got Fingered when I
was 12. you're not saying the word
you are so crazy
I go like this I want to be polite
you guys forget I Got Fingered but by a
19 year old when I was 12. I do forget
that often out I really like it I do
forget it so traumatized but every time
I relearn it it's like as exciting as
the person so it pops back in my head
usually in the middle of the night I
wake up
sweating twitching
um in a more enough to be formal I'm
very sorry that I have child abuse I
didn't know it was wrong at that time so
who cares that's not one of my core
wounds yeah it's not so weird like I had
a thing happen where I was filming this
like Hooters sketch I think I talked
about before but I was filming this
Hooters sketch and I was getting pushed
out the whole reason I came up with the
idea is I was with this girl
and we stopped at a Hooters because I
thought it'd be funny and there was a
drunk guy in a suit and he was being so
annoying and I thought he worked there
originally and when I realized didn't
work there was like we got to make a
sketch where he's the guy that works
there or something so then I made a
sketch where he was like he I came in to
get a job application and he pushes me
on he goes you have no tits like how
dare you try to work here and um it's
just it all came because this guy was
drunk and annoying so I knew when I
asked him to be in the sketch like I was
getting myself into a situation with an
annoying drunk man in a suit so the guy
ended up I had this girl who I was
friends with at the time filming and um
and the guy ended up like pulling my
hair he did something that was like too
much but I knew like going into it that
this guy was gonna end up being like a
problem sort of like pulling my hair or
something and I was like dude don't
[ __ ] pull me like I was like you're
going to you know I had to like slap him
or whatever you know and my friend like
and we ended up doing the sketch and
everything ended up being funny we leave
and the girl I was friends with was like
she was like what hate did to you was so
unacceptable and I was like
but no it's fine like I and she goes no
and she's like I need to have my
feelings about I was like no [ __ ]
you're trying to make this into like a
core wound for me I go no no no no no
because I could go there where I get
traumatized by this but I am accepting
responsibility for the fact that I got
it I literally said to a man talk to me
about my tits and push me physically so
you know what I mean but it was like she
wanted it so bad for it to be a core
wound that's such an interesting analogy
to like when a little kid falls and if
if you're like are you okay then they
start crying but if you're just like
you're fine like it's okay like she did
the bad version yes right you cannot
like force delegate a pain onto someone
no I think it's wrong because it's like
but also did you think it was wrong or
are you trying to have an emotion it
didn't happen to you yes that was like
what the hell because I used to with the
same girl I used to have a lot of like
problems where she would be like telling
me gossip about a person I had already
told her I didn't want to be friends
with like not in a mean way like it was
just someone that I didn't find
interesting and um do you know when you
when you encounter people as much
especially in this business and you go
like oh like I see my own death when I'm
talking to you like like time is like
ticking like I go like oh you're wasting
like what I have left on this earth like
that's who this person was to me and it
wasn't like it's no like disrespect like
I know that sounds so disrespectful but
like it's just like this is not my
person this doesn't make me laugh
because it doesn't elevate my life right
I'm like when I'm talking to you like I
could be doing anything else in the
world that makes me feel better than
talking to you and I just was like I
don't want to get like in this person's
drama and so we had this this person was
like a mutual friend and she kept
bringing this person up to me and I kept
going you're making me sound so mean I
don't have to keep like defending that I
want to be friends with this person it's
just a boundary it's not like no offense
I'm happy that you're friends with this
person but she would always come to me
she's like you're not even believe what
happened with her
this and I go this is I go I don't want
to talk about this person she goes I'm
allowed to tell you my feelings but it's
not your feelings it's your feelings
about someone else and I started under
this pattern with this person where it
was like everything was like an emotion
about something happening to someone
else it was like all gossipy and I was
like if it's about something that
happened to you I'll talk to you about
it but you know what I love what you
said is like you talk to someone you see
your own death you could be doing
anything else and then you're like but
no disrespect like I actually relate to
that so hard it's like there are people
I just like I don't want to go there and
then it's like but it's not an evil
thing on my part it's just like our Venn
diagrams don't like they don't need to
touch like we don't need to overlap at
all we can just be like living our
separate lives and it's like I want the
best for you in your life it's just it
cannot it I'm bored to tears around this
person bored to tears but there are
sometimes like instinct is everything
like I I always I always go back to my
sister having worked in in jails for
over 10 years so she's a very you guys
have just been through
[Applause]
she did a jails for 10 years so she is
very Discerning of types Predators
murderers she has to medically treat
people who just stab their wives so
she's almost like you almost kind of
have a she has a sixth sense for certain
types and I remember her meeting a
particular comic but she's like pointed
says like when she met you
had a particular male comic a couple
years ago and immediately she was like
no no kalila he is not not even just a
bad guy but dangerous he does bad things
interesting and I was like you're being
like really prematurely like you're
being judgy like he's a you know he's
blah blah blah and she was like no I'm
telling you it's like just wait a couple
years later let's try one down yeah and
she and you know but she is like high on
the discernment and sometimes like
people like if you get that feeling I
think that you should listen to that
feeling oh about this body I I don't
think you should just brush it off as oh
maybe I'm being judgmental you should
listen to it a little bit well it's just
you know I I I was listening to like one
of my mentors or one of the people
online or something and I remember them
saying whatever
if if someone doesn't like elevate your
life and doesn't like bring you that Joy
like you don't owe them like why would
you because that's like a weird
codependent thing like if I'm now
worrying about this person that I've
just and it's it's not like I'm not like
if I see this person I'm like I don't go
like oh I'm out of here or anything it's
just like I don't choose to like on
purpose hang out with this person or or
like I don't want them to text I don't
wanna they're just not yeah and by the
way just to prove it's like so not even
a rudeness I feel like I'm learning so
much about how when the way you're
raised that dictates like what kind of
personalities and people you're drawn to
so it could literally just be you guys
like you and this another person are
just not a match like literally yeah
even if you look the same whatever it is
um but I also I really trust people like
that who can read someone and tell you
like I trust that way more than what
you're saying about like your friend who
would just tell you like talk [ __ ] about
someone else it's like that I don't
trust that's like someone else's
experience but like when someone's like
no I have this weird gut instinct
because I've been around this type like
that's so valuable to me can I have your
sister's phone number oh scary figure to
my house her sister sorry she's met you
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
navigating any of life challenges can
make you feel unsure whether it's a
career change a new relationship or even
becoming a parent therapists are trained
to help you figure out the cause of
challenging emotions and learn
productive coping skills which makes
therapy the closest thing to a guided
tour of the complex engine called you as
the world's largest therapy service
better help has matched 3 million people
with professionally licensed and vetted
therapists available 100 online plus
it's affordable just fill out a brief
questionnaire to match with a therapist
and if things aren't clicking you can
easily switch to a new therapist anytime
it couldn't be simpler no waiting rooms
no traffic no endless searching for the
right therapist learn more and save 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
trash Tuesday that's betterhelp help.com
trash Tuesday
okay so I actually have
um sort of an aligned just like a
friendship question that I really feel
like it is my issue but I want to get
your guys's advice I have a friend who I
love so much and
I feel like I see her making decisions
that like are not good for her and like
maybe like hung up on a guy that it's
just I think that's like the big issue
and I find myself wanting to be like hey
here's what I think I think this and I
think this and I want to help you and
it's all coming from this place of like
wanting to help her but I know just like
through experience nobody listens to you
when you do that right like I just want
to confirm that I'm like there's nothing
that can be done right it's you cannot
do it unsolicited if she comes to you
then that's the only time you speak
because if you push your like heavy
opinions on her you're no longer going
to be the person she turns to or even
opens up to because she's gonna be like
oh she's it's gonna be a she's gonna
expect that I Told You So Vibe and I
know what you mean it's really difficult
not to intervene and I've definitely
been in this situation where I want to
shake somebody and be like look can you
not see yeah that you know one plus one
equals two the result of everything that
you're experiencing is because of this
person but you just you just can't
Esther what the [ __ ] that's crazy to me
like what what would you do if I would
just tell them I don't give a [ __ ] I
would I would just go look like maybe
this isn't what you want to hear but the
problem is like I hate when I get into
that part of relationships friendships
where it's like things get Snappy like I
hate because people will get mad because
they'll defend they want to believe this
is a person you know like people will
defend these guys right like they'll be
like all right no but he loves me even
though he doesn't like call me until
it's like three in the morning or
whatever I'm just making up an example
and you can see that this is a guy
that's like not treating your friend
well you know you can see that but it's
like like even with I feel like you've
done this for me before you've been like
look
I know you probably don't want to hear
this but like as your friend I I really
like the approach my sister takes with
me when she knows I'm dating a scumbag
and I take a very different approach
from her because when she was dating an
abusive [ __ ] for six years I was always
in her face like look at him he's a
[ __ ] this like look what he's doing
like but she was so in it that
eventually I sort of like there was a
distance between us because she couldn't
come to me anymore about yeah regarding
him right eventually they broke up
um I wish a lot of times that I held my
tongue because it wasn't my place it's
her journey it's her life my sister
takes a different approach with me when
I have dated scumbags she just Waits
she's like I trust my sister to figure
it out she's gonna have a maybe a couple
years of a lot of pain but when she's
ready to talk about it I'm gonna give
her my honest opinion but she just
doesn't meddle and I really really
respect her for that okay she lets me
learn my hard lessons but in your case
it has been going on for 10 years and
also it's like I I think you hold you
hold back as much as you can and then
when you can no longer say it there's a
reason you can no longer say because
maybe it's crossing a boundary for you
at this point where you're like I'm just
getting all these like terrible
tales and I have to just sit by them do
you know what I mean would you want it
if someone intervened unsolicited with
you and saying Esther look I actually
think you're a lesbian I
I actually think back to a time where I
was dating a guy where he was clearly
just like would come over after he got
off work and have sex with me and leave
and didn't sleep over because he said he
couldn't find parking like I was in that
situation and I had my friend who was my
famously crazy roommate that we all know
she sat me who was older than me and
wiser and she's like here's the facts
like he doesn't respect you he doesn't
like you he comes over after work and
even though I was like still I remember
still being like I like him you know I
did hear her and was like
okay those are interesting things she's
saying like but I almost I like
I like to digest feedback like I I
weirdly like love it and welcome it
which I think a lot of people do I would
think but it seems like I don't know I
think oh sorry I can promise you that if
you were to come on strong to this
person that you're not gonna get the
intended result
I could promise you that but maybe you
don't have to come on strong maybe you
do like what you did with me where you
were like look this is like probably not
what you want to hear
but this is like my opinion and this is
what I'm seeing and like as your friend
who wants you to be treated well
I don't this isn't like a way I would
like you to be treated because I find
myself pulling back as a friend because
you don't want to yeah exactly and I
hate that and that makes me so sad but
I'm like well this is kind of the right
boundary I think is to just be like okay
they that like and this even with my
sister I go through this and and friend
here a friend there it's like okay this
person is making a life choice I don't
agree with my instinct is to like
[ __ ] bum rush them and tell them
everything they're doing wrong that
doesn't work I've learned that so like
just sit back and but also working is
like feeling like like what you say has
to have like a specific outcome you just
need to say what you need to say like
because it's it is affecting your
friendship yeah it is it's affecting
your friendship so what do you need to
say for yourself to help your friendship
the difficult part is if this person is
coming to you always downtrodden you
know saying I feel my life is in
shambles that's when it's like all right
like you you want Solutions or do you
want Comfort right like choose one
choose a [ __ ] Lane you know what I've
heard Whitney asked me that before do
you want Solutions or do you want
comfort and I was like Comfort obviously
yeah have you met me that was so smart
and you're I forgot about that I should
ask people that because it is about your
boundary and what you're willing to to
take in this situation because she's in
a habit of like a bad but wait for an
opening and the opening has to come from
her okay because then it's going to
cause like attention and like I I just
don't think that that's the way like I
think that's very meddling if you come
like unannounced and you're like hey
what's up so here are my thoughts no
you're not gonna do that well
wait that's so funny hi I need to talk
to you I would kill myself if you
comment we're like hi I need to talk to
you I would jump off a bridge like no
you don't
no one's talking to me
I don't know what do you guys think like
um I'd love to know how people handle
yeah because tricky situations and
friendships I do think this is a common
thing that comes up and like I feel like
I'm just the one that's feeling it this
week you know like I just feel like if
it's if it's frustrating you that's the
issue it's like what is frustrating
about it is there something you can
detach from but it's like you can't give
advice expecting people to take it
either it's like you can say something
because I feel like with you what you
said to me was like a sentiment sort of
like for the future like
you might not want to hear this now you
know but it was like good to hear it's
like even though it's annoying because
you want someone to be like no I think
he really does like you it's just he you
know
just going through something during the
day during the time sorry other people
see you all together that's not my story
I had a friend who I intervened very
hard with and she was with this guy who
was just very like 50 in with her and
she was this gorgeous successful
um long time friend of mine and I just
saw this dude just completely take her
you know take her for a ride take
advantage of her time but she was like
Khalil I think he's just going through
something I was like he's not he's just
he doesn't like you and I was so firm on
that I was so firm on that she stuck
around and she hung in there she's like
I just have a feeling I think he can get
there for me and you know what I was
wrong he got there for her and they have
three kids now yeah and that's where
it's like her instinct is overriding
yours because she's in it and there's
things that you're that you're not
seeing that's weird though but if you're
always prefacing as this is my opinion
like I I had a friendship that actually
ended over this girl that I really like
I cared about she was dated someone who
she had said like the the person had
broken up with her and then
um she told like was trying to still be
friends with her and she was like no my
feelings are to her like my heart is
broken like I can't be friends and then
that person kept pursuing this
friendship and I was like this person
sounds like a piece of [ __ ] like I was
like what the hell is this like they're
breaking your boundaries like and she
got so mad it started screaming you
don't know you don't know this person
and I'm like I only knew what you told
me I know all of the information you
told me and I'm not saying I'm just
telling you like as your friend I care
about you I would like people to treat
you with the respect you know and then
there was a quick boundary set with me
and I did respect it bye see you later a
boundary that I also learned for myself
is I don't tell my family
um uh difficulties in my relationship I
don't share that because I always want
them to have like a good good feelings
for my partner so it's like if I if I'm
like if he did something that really
piss me off like my first phone call
isn't to my family it's like we're gonna
work it out first because it stays fixed
in their head yeah and that version that
of whatever information you're telling
them becomes a different picture of who
they actually are so you've already
moved on from the problem but they
haven't yet now they think that this guy
is just this and that and that's why I
never that's like my number one rule I
don't turn to my family about like
relationship problems I think we've all
made that mistake before where you like
talk so much [ __ ] on your boyfriend and
then like you're at Thanksgiving like
why does nobody like him exactly yeah
why are you guys mad at him
yeah I don't know I guess I'm just like
I am brutally honest and it's just the
way I am and it's you know
maybe not the right thing for people
that want to hear a certain thing but I
just that's just how I operate yeah
maybe maybe that then I need to sort of
take inspiration from what you just said
and be like you know what this is how I
operate too when it's like if if this
the next time this person like complains
about something in that area like maybe
I'm just gonna be who I really am and
respond honestly and like be true to
myself and I think that is being true to
them as well and like whatever right
because because if you're worried about
like the way she reacts it's like you're
not it's like so codependent it's like
you don't have control over how she acts
anyway and even though like you can know
you can have some ideas of what might
happen it's still bothering you so the
way like it's bothering you enough to
bring it up here you know yeah and it's
just so it's about you you're busy you
have [ __ ] you're doing you're like
creating a whole thing you're
entertaining you're doing all these
things so it's like do you have time to
just sit and swallow
your thoughts or do you need to just
speak your
your mind and trust that whatever's
gonna happen the Friendship is what's
supposed to happen with the Friendship
yeah I like that now I know earlier we
talked about codes when you meet someone
and your codes just don't match and
automatically you feel like I don't want
to know this person a waste of time
um recently I was reading about the
Nobel Peace Prize winner the woman who
basically proved the theory of quantum
entanglement which is if you split two
particles no matter the distance seven
centimeters apart or seven light years
apart if you charge this particle this
one will also charge oh so cute Max I
don't know I know I thought of you sexy
but do you think like I don't know what
that proves in terms of like like how
like humanity is interconnected and
whatnot but do you think that because I
always never used to believe in fate or
destiny I was making myself emo I'm like
about to cry
I was thinking that so I was like you
are forever to charge party yeah you
were just split particles
but now it's like science like fully
accepts it they've always talked about
it but now you're like oh like this is
the thing maybe and I always thought
like Faith or meeting someone and me
even manifestation is like all bogus but
when I read more about it I was like oh
[ __ ] like have I been wrong I've always
I've always loved the idea of just
everything being random everything's
just chance but then I'm like no like
what if there's a Charged particle out
there for me but you know what also I
think the theory not that I've read the
[ __ ] thing I'm just going off of
literally the two sentences that you
[ __ ] said so by the way I also have I
don't know any any of it but maybe the
split particle idea it's not that they
come together right it's that even
separated they can charge each other so
it's like you it's like it's like
someone maybe you don't even ever need
to meet or maybe it's someone you
already met yeah well ex-boyfriend girl
she loves this [ __ ] she loves
ex-boyfriends I was thinking about this
I'm 50 50 on the ex-boyfriends because
well you're growing you're growing why
you could put one ex-boyfriend in front
of me right now and I would rip his dick
off his butt yeah I hate him so [ __ ]
well of course you don't have to have
all you don't like all of them I only
have like two ex-boyfriend friends who
are like not friends but like you know
like Brian redband I love my I love
Brian I love my exes so much we're like
a family except one estranged family
member knock you out [ __ ] that one
cousin that just don't want to come to
the reunion I'll find you wait maybe
he's your split particle and that's why
you feel so strongly and you don't need
to see him he can just charge you I
don't even want to think that I [ __ ]
hate him I don't want any connection to
him I love yes you do that's the
funniest word no it's like so hard no
like the fact that he has like a bit has
banned me from his life so permanently
I'm like stay then stay banned well
that's why you know you're not over him
because you said hate and hate is the
opposite of love hate is not the
opposite of
nightmare was the opposite of a
nightmare what is the opposite of Love
um disinterest this interest like uh
um indifference indifference yeah yeah
so if there's hate there there's still
some love there unfortunately why yeah I
am mad at being having a life ban from
him
it's so funny don't worry I'm still
seeking out Bradley vanderkam he has not
accepted my Facebook friend request in
17 years did you tell him that Carlos
worked at his grandmother's
dog shop
oh Vander Camp sorry
brother says his grandma
so much
um he was a college boyfriend I dated
him for three months and I cheated on
him with a boy when I went to Mexico and
he was like we're done and he was so
done like he never forgave me never gave
me he like straight up just iced me out
even to this day so I know the feeling
Esther but I I don't feel like a hate or
a love I just I respect it I just keep
thinking about when I'm in Mexico
but I'm trying to make it Mexico Mexico
no matter where I go I'm gonna [ __ ]
another guy in Mexico
what is this Tupac the Tupac song
um
I like when my ex-boyfriends are like
I'm good I love a boundary but you know
what I think I Had No Boundaries as a
kid like I used to always say when
McDonald's like let you have breakfast
all day I was like this it was
devastating for me that was the only
time in my life someone was like no
[ __ ] and I was like okay thank you
hey all right that's never happened you
like that too I actually totally agree
yeah it's like I you you I like
discipline as well like set tell me
where it is but you like discipline so
you can get in eventually and he's not
letting you in he's just giving you the
yeah cut me off you want to be cut off
yeah cut me off like you cannot over
allow me to over indulge in anything
because I will yeah it's no longer
fun to consume you should cast them in
your movie oh the boyfriends
I
I think that this age Esther like 34 and
like cut me off I love it but I think
like I'm it's like
from that age is like traumatic to be
cut off well you can't believe well you
I think my idea of friendship and
everything was so forever for me when I
was young it was I used to have like a
my like phone list you know from before
cell phones I had like my phone list of
all my friends and I was just like I
just had all you know I went to these
like Quaker youth Retreats I always had
friends that like lived in different
places that I met from different things
and I just always like thought I was
gonna stay connected ever and so when
people were like I'm good it was so like
devastating but then a really good
lesson
because now I'm like to other people can
I tell you guys a cute story you know
however like a phone numbers are
basically like obsolete who gives a [ __ ]
you can just about get a hold of anybody
Instagram social media directly you know
um tweet at them but I got a love letter
okay so tigerbelly has
um obviously our Factory like our merch
guys and somebody sent this love letter
to our customer service
and I just think it's so cute because
I'm like what is the mindset here like
what is he thinking and why did he send
it to customer service of her like
that's how easy
can I read it to you do you not feel
scared I well I I find stranger danger
of these I've gotten I've gotten love
life yeah I don't ages like them from
from prisoners
well anyone that's sending you a love
letter could be in prison wait what what
did what are you saying that we're gonna
encourage more of this stalkers I
thought it was really sweet and I
thought I think maybe it's she doesn't
do you really think it's sweet or yeah
because when you read it okay yeah well
maybe not she doesn't go on the road you
just need to do one meet and greet girl
you'll be fine you'll get it all oh no
I've had I've been groped I've been
groped by uh drunk uh men after bobby
shows yes many times
um heavy hot breath on me it's I've done
it all
um
breath
um I'm sad to hear of the breakup news
between Bobby and kalila a few months
ago but I'm happy to hear now that both
Bobby and Khalil are doing well and
moving on with their lives
tell me if you feel a stalker Vibe I'm
already scared I've often
I've often thought when watching the
podcast that kaleila is amazing in so
many ways and I'm just wondering if you
would consider forwarding my email to
her in case she's open to meeting a good
dude yes with a belly and a chaotic life
but a good dude I'm nothing special look
looks wise and I'm certainly not famous
but we could get along great for a
number of reasons and her smile truly
makes me melt Love George Kimmel
anyways blah blah blah blah would love
the opportunity to communicate with
khalila sometime and possibly become her
friend or who knows dot dot dot
there's like 20 million of these I know
book The more service
like if it was a DM I'd probably be like
who cares it's like the effort that gets
you yeah that's the scary part to me if
you go to a second location to send me
something I'm terrified what other
lengths will you go through Carlos time
I
oh yeah sorry my thoughts are that um
that's really easy to write and any
crazy person yes put together a bunch of
sentences it wasn't nice enough to you
either yeah
is hacky
like it's like hitting a girl up on
LinkedIn or something it's like a weird
route yeah
I think the yeah I think that's creepy
LinkedIn
well we don't have LinkedIn so they want
to get their Lincoln
their sausage
banana break
[Music]
I don't know why I'm always trying to
find you a husband
we gotta get her married you know you're
very Filipino in that way
you're very wifey though your wifey
you've been through enough I'm like
you're just ready to find someone that's
just gonna I really do think that no
like play more but for like a year I
just feel like your mother how long do
you think I should play around for I
have a hard time I think it's like you
don't even give any thought to how long
it's like just
I I do think that we're all kind of like
boyfriend girls like I feel like we're
all the kind of girl so you're trying to
get her to [ __ ] for us you know like
that's like never single long like I
always run right after when I get dumped
because I've only ever been dumped
um I always think like oh my God I'm
gonna be single forever
and then I always get a boyfriend really
fast I've been single for years at a
time really years and years now uh-huh
I would go through just bouts of being
completely asexual oh sorry sorry say
that again Annie I thought my hair was
like being completely like asexual and
stuff like that but wait this is what I
wanted to tell you that Wayne Dyer said
today on this thing that was listening
to that's so good he goes life itself is
a sexually transmitted terminal disease
isn't that so good what does it mean
it's like we're gonna die we're sexually
transmitted and we're gonna die oh
that's funny because he was talking
about like like using your imagination
and like I am statements so like
whatever you want to be you just create
you know just I am I am I am and he was
saying that
um I am a TD well he had he had leukemia
while I was talking about this so he was
like I'm not saying to say that you're
he's like I know that I have I have
leukemia and I know that this does like
I have an understanding of what it does
to your body and what the limitations
people say it does he goes but
um you can't say like I am going to live
forever he's like but I do think that
you can live each moment like its
fullest and its brightest and he's like
since my diagnosis I've had such amazing
like bursts of Brilliance in my life or
whatever but it was cool it was just
like a random thing I listened to but I
thought that was funny I always trust
when people either at the end of their
life or going through some terminal
illness like I always listen extra
carefully to what they're saying because
I feel like they sort of crack the code
of life in those really difficult
moments I love to hear the morsels of
wisdom from them well that probably
dropped the like ego part of it you know
because it's like they're not like it's
not about like flashiness or anything
like all like The Superficial stuff has
got to go away at that point I would
think because you're like all right I
don't have time to [ __ ] focus on that
I only have time to focus on the real
like deep stuff over you say sorry no I
just agree with all that it feels like
people in those positions like know and
feel things that we just can't reach or
grasp yet and
like there is something to going through
difficult tragic things like I feel like
all of our great thinkers always are
commenting on how like life is just
about how you react to your all the
tragedies that are coming like because
what you were all walking STDs it's like
there's no other
we all lose our loved ones that it just
happens you know yeah it doesn't matter
if your [ __ ] Bella Hadid it's like
you're still a human you're still going
to experience pain and all that [ __ ] so
like don't pre we can't hide from it
have we moved on to Bella now well we've
been redacted we've been rejected by
everyone else
Jesus I'm gonna get one of you yeah
Bella I know your sister I feel like she
wouldn't diss you like Kendall I
actually kind of agree I disagree
I like the idea of like everyone's gonna
diss you and then they'll come around
like they're all gonna be like do you
remember when we thought this was a
creep
um I listened to
a podcast called the history of Fire
and I was so energized and inspired by
this one story where basically in the
1800s this Chinese woman who was a
prostitute she was working in the
floating brothels like I guess she was
one of the women that would have sex
with like the Pirates and a floating
brothel that should um and and she uh
worked her way up to being the leader of
the largest pirate Confederacy in
history bigger than even like who's the
most famous like pirate ever like
Blackbeard she really blow hold her way
to the top she really [ __ ] did like
they're they're saying like her Fleet or
her her Confederacy was like 80 000
people and Blackbeard only had like an
eighth of that and this woman
relatively unknown are they gonna say
this woman is still something I was like
she's alive
1800s but like I don't know
there isn't a lot of
um literature about her you know
everyone's always like Blackbeard
Blackbeard and this badass [ __ ]
basically she was Blackbeard's beard
Blackbeard was gay guys yeah there she
is oh she's cute but that's like my
favorite storyline same and peaky
blinders with this woman who was just
one of Tommy Shelby's um horse
eventually became like one of the
strongest in the show look at that's a
power [ __ ] she banned rape
yeah is that her name what happened back
in the day if you gave like a toothy
[ __ ] there's three of the Sharks
they're like this is a floating brothel
[ __ ] you're done well that's how like
the well one of when I took a marine
biology class one of the stories that my
professor used to say is like with the
idea of mermaids actually came from
drunk Pirates accidentally having sex
whatever that's so funny right like I
don't know how true that is but it's
apparently like these drunk Pirates
would just their face is so funny don't
you feel like if we were pirates Carlos
to be the first one to [ __ ] a manatee no
we think he was a manatee he would get
[ __ ] I think he was a manatee Carlos
come on I wouldn't [ __ ] a man oh my God
I wouldn't have you stop it man did you
say a tea or did you just stop by in
here
I wouldn't have gone on these [ __ ]
boats I had been royalty in Spain
the
world
get you oh I would give you you love a
prostate I would give all the
prostitutes my gold on this ship if I
was your mom's gold yeah
Herrera Spain
but I thought of you Esther I was like
oh I think you have that kind of like a
perfect
strategy in you to go from
[ __ ] to like you know what I mean like
working out her this is her she's like
you do look like you're about to get
outed for something you're like don't
for being an escort secretly
[ __ ] cool though oh I love that you
know I love stories like that I mean I I
idolize growing up I idolized I know
everyone hates you for this but like Amy
Fisher Jenna Jameson Trisha Paytas like
Ann Nicole Smith like I love when a
woman like uses her sexuality like
emrada even does it and like even though
I don't
like even though her work isn't like my
thing exactly I love the concept that
emrata is like
was so hot in this music video
that there were three naked women in it
and the only one everyone remembers is
her so she's clearly like this like like
do you think any of them are gonna have
their like Kelly moment though I hope so
but like and then she's taken that
success and is now a podcaster an author
and like
I just think that is like the goal that
is so wonderful that she's doing that
and like I said even though I'm not it's
not like content for me necessarily I
love I see you I love you kind of thing
Jenna Jameson
her book was incredible her book her
life story of how she was 15 years old
and wanted to work at the strip club and
[ __ ] took her with pliers ripped her
braces out herself like went I just a
woman who's like in a troubling
situation and like takes action and
makes choices like that to me I love
when the woman is in the driver's seat
like making her life happen wearing
sitting on so many phone books yeah
it is such a like complicated area where
men get so angry and I know like I've
seen the comments where people get so
mad at me that I look up to these women
that are like supposedly bad whatever
but I feel like people don't understand
that when you're a girl there's not that
many powerful icon Idols that we had to
look up to right like I understand if
you're a guy you think oh my God I can
be president I can do anything all them
powerful people in the world are men but
like when you're a girl
you've got to be more creative and so I
like why does someone like Jenna Jameson
have to just be like all the bad things
you want to say about her why can't I
look at her story and see the good in it
and think that's cool and same for like
bad baby and like everyone else like I'm
just give us like some wiggle room to
view things differently and to be
inspired and see the good and stuff but
it is this like misogynist
um
like preaching that or whatever like
that people just you're not allowed to
do that and even imrada to her credit is
like people tell me they don't want like
why is she writing why is she podcasting
like
well what is she supposed to do just
like shake her tits that's all she's
allowed to have like no let she can do
it might not be for you you don't have
to listen right but you don't have to
trash it like let us all do our thing it
just people don't see it from our
perspective because they're usually guys
and they're mad at us because we want
one trick pony is all you'll be yeah but
also easier to digest it's like you are
one thing and one thing only it kind of
a short circuits a lot of people's
brains when you are four things five
things yeah you can do more than just
podcasts when you can do more than just
be a model it's like God forbid you
allow us
um a 3D like the respect of knowing like
we're 3D but that's why we have to just
ignore those people like and not neither
but that's the [ __ ] annoying part
right it's like because you do you're
just like what the hell is this like
it's so crazy to be like I know I talk
about this all the time and I've talked
about it on anniewood
um but like it is just like so
um like you're
like mad at me for being a [ __ ] when I
was a kid like why is anyone mad that I
was a [ __ ] when I was young like why
would a stranger care if I was like a
[ __ ] in high school after being a lead
like why is that like a problem but then
I'm like why am I even like paying it
that's crazy for me to even pay
attention to that it's like everyone
like when people used to say that I
there was like a rumor spread that I
like hooked up with the booker to get
into this um Festival which was just so
asinine it was like so crazy to me I was
like what the what have I ever done
[ __ ] anything like that except like
reject people that are trying to do that
with me and so that was like so
upsetting and then I remember Whitney
being like she's like yeah but even if
you did if it was true like why would it
matter I'm like no no I'm not no but it
didn't happen like so it's like it's a
separate thing it's like but that's not
the truth I didn't do that I don't use
those things like overtly in that way to
get things I never have however that
doesn't mean I'm judging someone else
that does or whatever it's just like and
maybe sometimes I am maybe sometimes I'm
like oh I don't like that that's not for
me but everyone should be making the
best out of like whatever their
situation is like get your exit out this
is we're all in our own [ __ ] escape
room you know it's like find your way
out solve the world all the way over
however well you I don't know why I'm
making an escape room analogy I've never
been I've never been to an escape
they're actually so [ __ ] fun I'd
never want to go to one but to okay no
you would be so annoying in an escape
room that little princess in the escape
room she's like I'm cold to those people
though who want you know whether it's a
woman whoever to just be that one thing
to be the naked girl whatever the and
whatever one thing you want to be are
you one thing out there are you just an
incel is that all you are no you're more
than that like we all have more than one
thing about us so like we're all the
[ __ ] and also we're all the same you
know what's so funny that we literally
do have like such an audience of people
that just watch us to like to hate us be
mad at us it's so funny like normally
I'd be like who are you even talking to
but it is crazy it's like they're
getting like you guys are our fans
that's the thing you guys like us we're
just here if you keep watching it to
complain about it like you like us wait
you guys um I know that you like us do
you like us
either way clicking you know yeah I like
her about
um do we believe in New Year's
resolutions did we already established
this last year
um I feel like what I remember the
sentiment of it was like we don't like
to put pressure on a specific time yeah
can we can you give me your high and
your highs and your lows this year give
me one high one low
and one hope for the next year okay
I have one okay go okay so I am I just
started my Annie wood podcast and I feel
like I'm really excited because I'm
putting like um it feels like my artwork
kind of like I'm really like trying to
create something and Todd's helping me
that's like really cool and I want to
grow it as like things that I really
like and not worry about what people
think about it like numbers like I want
to be doing it like true to like what I
really like rather than like trying to
get
like anything out of it do you know what
I mean I wanna and I want to go through
that with like my project but I want to
do that with like all of the stuff that
I do like with my stand-up and stuff too
like I don't want to get like caught up
in like
people's like
I don't know I don't want to be like
focused on the result I want to be like
in the moment of what I'm doing and like
make everything
like just love what I'm doing right so
that's the Hope any highs and lows of
2020. I don't know what that means oh of
the last of past year yeah highs and
lows I have a high which was okay I was
so
terrified and it's not even that big of
a deal but in February I flew to New
York like just with the
um purpose to get past the comedy seller
and like I was so scared and even like
days leading up to my audition I was
like I don't need to do this I was like
I don't even need to do this why am I
doing this I'm never in New York like I
don't need to be a pastor I my brain
like tried to talk me out of it I was so
nervous and I [ __ ] somehow someway
did it got past and I just I think
knowing how scared I was and that I
actually went through and got the
positive result and like feel that it I
don't know I just why did you do that in
February so weird and like so I just
feel good about that because I feel like
stand up
is just a thing where I don't know I
think the New York scene when I think
about it's like all these like angry old
guys who just like hate everybody and
I'm like well no I went up I went to
your Club I got past there like I can
perform that there now whenever I want
to so that was like a good like high
batch of Honor they're fun too the New
York people are so the New York Comics
are fun as hell [ __ ] yeah they are fun I
would say my low is pretty obvious I
went through a breakup and the pain of
that I am just getting over
um but a high for me is definitely going
home reconnecting but a really recent
high for me is
um
finding my friendship with Bobby again
in like a way that is like I could cry
thinking about it it's so much more
meaningful than I think it's ever been
and it feels like genuine and it feels
like it's like very life-affirming I'm
like holy [ __ ] like
I really love this person the Romantic
door is closed but like I [ __ ] love
this person and I'm gonna be friends
with them for the rest of my life so it
was kind of like an ending and a
beginning again so yeah
like finding my love for him in a
different way is a high for me I am so
happy to hear yeah that's so cute both
of yours is very special because I love
you both so much and like I need I
needed that for me but also it seems
like better because it's like it was
like if you're in a relationship that's
like not giving you what you want then
you're like upset all the time and it's
like you missed like the whole reason
you were together anyway is that you
like enjoyed each other and there's then
you don't have like those same
expectations of each other and you can
just kind of like let it breathe and be
good yeah
yeah my my low was probably I feel like
this summer which Carlos maybe remembers
like I feel like I just like meandered a
lot of time and I was waiting for stuff
that like wasn't happening I just feel
like I let that like control me and I
didn't and I feel like I didn't really
like till the Fall start learning to
like look within and like be more
creative and so I feel like I Meander
time just like because of insecurity or
something this summer a little I feel
like that time is also really necessary
though I'm learning to like live in the
in between the discomfort the not
knowing for so I'm usually the type of
person where it's like nope I need to be
super decisive I need to know and answer
almost like immediately and
um one of the things that I worked that
I've been working on in therapy the most
is allowing the discomfort of the like
she calls it like a liminal space and
even if liminal space is just an
in-between space like between here and
there and I'm so uncomfortable in this
hey Meander a lot and I wake up like how
what am I have all these things swirling
in my head but I can't seem to pull the
trigger on anything and
um but I'm learning that that is very
very you're used that is time not wasted
that is time necessary to actually get
to a place where you need to be so wow
you want I don't think that that's a bad
thing I need to take that in because I
that is like painful to me like the
Meandering I think about it and but like
waiting for things to suck so it's like
we just do something else yeah you
started a [ __ ]
um tie-dye business you know what I mean
like there's a million things to do yeah
so I'm like mad that I let that do the
best of me but you know but it's nothing
and you probably just needed rest too
it's like yeah it's like listen to your
body it's always the right thing like I
feel like that's what it like always
helps me it's like whenever I'm upset
about something it's like everything's
happening exactly as it's how it's
supposed to happen and I feel like just
from my like ego deaths and doing
hallucinogens and stuff it's like I feel
like the lesson I'm always getting is
like oh [ __ ] everyone everything's like
was always supposed to be like this so
it's like no reason to
like correct fret Carlos a hope for next
year a high and a low and a hope a low
he was like the butt tape moment yeah
right that was a high I yeah I felt
that's when you fell in love I feel like
yeah maybe that was a high because I was
surprised that my butthole was like not
like horrible to witness no it's so
pretty thank you what I appreciate that
Annie I feel like you liked it I was
indifferent the opposite of Love
such a flex
um and okay so high a high a high from
this past year
um I really liked our trip to New York
when we went to flagrant
I was like yeah that was fun and it was
the first day of the Ukrainian War oh my
God you want you know what that says to
me that you guys were sitting in a hotel
watching the news
hope for next year
just that like bad friends does really
well and that I have a good time on bad
friends that's mostly it is that I more
focus on that show what
um okay yeah I hope bad friends does
well their tour goes well and yeah yeah
hope Andrew sells a lot of tickets
yeah Santino that's sweet thanks Carlos
thanks for sharing my hi wait I want to
say Milo was working with Carlos do it
over again I didn't do mine yet I didn't
do my eyes on those I just had my hopes
um my yeah my high was not being on
Carlos's High the one time he wasn't
hanging out with me that's cool
um
um
no my high was I don't know my whole
year has been so good I feel like I've
been so happy I love my boyfriend I love
my dog I love my family I feel like
really like forgiving my parents having
like really a new relationship with them
has been amazing going on the road has
been a high I love meeting everyone
and starting my new podcast has been
amazing and then
um my low I don't really feel like I had
like a low I mean I think I went through
a lot of stuff but it's like it was just
like processing things and
it was good everything's been so good no
lows baby yeah wait I think my hope is
um I'm choosing this sorry
anyway
she doesn't
the sugars I actually already had apple
juice today
um yeah it's complicated
uh my hope is I want to read and journal
more and like get more introspective in
2023 because that I think is like what I
wish I had done this summer and I didn't
and so what did you do when you were
like Meandering I don't know
you don't have memory of it no I'm like
yeah there was like I feel like you wish
you had learned that's so cute I feel
like I just did nothing but like
stagnant yeah yeah
like I don't know what I did yeah
stagnation also I never remember what
was the summer
what was the summer see
I don't know what time is like I don't
I'm like I have a jacket it's like is it
winter
it's New Year's what's happening
well on that note it was a fun trip
honestly been fun with you girls that's
cheers to another year with all of our
sluggies yes
cheers you guys thank you for a great
year with us I'm kind of a ride we do
realize yeah yeah we love it all the
same yeah and we we were appreciative
that we found our tribe of slugs and
we're on to new things no more
[ __ ]
we're dropping some things okay
happy New Year happy New Year everybody
[Music]
all right
foreign